toujours au nom de l'assemblée générale
j'ai l'honneur de souhaiter la bienvenue
aux nations unies à monsieur frank
walter steinmeier
président de la république fédérale
d'allemagne je vous invite à prendre la
parole devant l'assemblée
l'abs end monsieur le président
chers collègues mesdames et messieurs
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les ambassadeurs
mesdames et messieurs les délégués ici à
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
nous nous réunissons ici dans ce
dans cette
auguste salle alors que les derniers
meetings de campagne ont lieu en
allemagne après demain 60 millions
d'allemands auront à élire un nouveau
parlement ils décideront de nouvelles
coalitions et décideront de qui sera le
successeur d'alan chancelière fédérale
qui a dirigé
l'allemagne ces seize dernières années
chers collègues alors que mon pays ait
connu une transition politique je vous
dis je tiens à vous assurer que du fait
que après cette élection l'allemagne
continuera d'être un pays qui est
conscient de ses responsabilités
internationales et qui les assume et il
y a deux raisons à cela tout d'abord
nous les allemands nous n'avons pas
oublié nous n'avons pas oublié la
renaissance économique politique après
la deuxième guerre mondiale après deux
guerres mondiales par dans et le chemin
qui a été le nôtre pour revenir
dans la communauté internationale après
tout les horreurs dans mon pays a été
responsable et enfin notre réunification
dans la paix ce ce cheminement
n'a été possible que grâce avec le
soutien de nos voisins et de nos
partenaires et deuxièmement parce que
nous sommes convaincus que le chemin
devant nous mener à un avenir plus
pacifique
que le règlement de toutes les questions
auxquelles l'humanité est confrontée
supposera beaucoup plus de coopération
le préambule de la loi organique
allemande
reflète notre aspiration en des termes
bref mais très précis promouvoir une
paix dans le monde en tant que
partenaire
sur un pied d'égalité dans une europe
unie or cette aspiration cette
obligation et une inspiration qui habite
qui a toujours habité tous les
gouvernements allemands c'est la raison
pour laquelle il était important pour
moi de venir à new york aujourd'hui en
tant que président de la république et
râle d'allemagne et de transmettre ce
message venant de l'allemagne à la
communauté internationale nos
partenaires pourront continuer de
compter sur nous nos concurrents eux
devront continuer faire attention
à mes yeux
notre responsabilité en matière de
politique étrangère commencent suppose
tout d'abord de commencer par examiner
de manière franche et honnête le monde
les orateurs qui ont pris la parole ici
à l'occasion de cette session de
l'assemblée générale ont été
particulièrement de francs cette année
est en fait la situation aujourd'hui et
par de nombreux égards
dégrisante la chute de kaboul constitue
un tournant nous avons atteint notre
objectif qui était de de vaincre ceux
qui ont causé une terreur sans nom dans
cette ville il ya de cela vingt ans
cependant
malgré
des efforts d investissement conséquent
nous n'avons pas été en mesure en vingt
ans de mettre en place
un ordre politique stable en afghanistan
et mon pays a également sa part de
responsabilité nous avons une part de
responsabilité une responsabilité qui
est d'actualité notamment vis-à-vis des
nombreux afghans qui aurait qui avait
espéré pouvoir jouir d'un avenir
démocratique et libre pacifique
cependant je pense que nous devons quand
même nous poser des questions quelles
conclusions allons nous tirer de cet
échec quels enseignements pouvons nous
tirer que pouvons nous encore faire
compte-tenu bien sûr du fait que nous
avons pêché par notre volonté d'en faire
trop je suis convaincu en tout cas que
le fait de se rendre eux n'est pas une
n'est pas une option et ce ne serait pas
le bon enseignement à tirer de cette
crise à mon avis ce moment de
désenchantement géopolitique pour ainsi
dire
renferme trois messages pour notre
politique étrangère nous devons faire
preuve de davantage d'honnêteté de plus
d'intelligence et de plus de force
nous devons faire preuve donc plus de
l'été je les deals dans l'examen des
options qu'il des possibilités qui nous
sont offertes dans les faits même de nos
limites nous devons être plus réaliste
également dans la définition et dans
l'établissement des priorités notamment
pour ce qui de nos objectifs de nos
intérêts nous pouvons faire davantage si
nous voulons s'il nous avons des
objectifs plus raisonnable ensuite nous
devons comme je l'étais faire preuve de
plus d'intelligence plus d'intelligence
dans la sélection des instruments dans
le choix des priorités l'allemagne et la
politique et c'est sa politique
étrangère ne doit pas se limiter à être
la bonne et à voix dire quelle est la
meilleure et a condamné les autres ce
dont nous avons besoin c'est d'élargir
notre les outils qui sont à notre
disposition diplomatiques militaires
civiles humanitaire et pour me et pour
moi pardon être plus intelligent cela
veut dire avant être plus ouverts avant
à voir - le sens du devoir et être plus
ouvert dans notre volonté de trouver des
solutions potentielles et des points
communs avec ceux qui sont différents de
nous et enfin troisièmement et même si
ça pourra vous paraître paradoxal nous
devons être plus fort lorsqu'il s'agit
de mettre les moyens dans tous nos pays
les citoyens attendent des gouvernements
de les protéger de les protéger donc
d'éventuelles menaces ou attaque et ils
ont raison c'est la raison pour laquelle
ans est dans cette époque très très
incertain mon pays lui aussi investi
davantage dans ses capacités de défense
sont maintenant il est clair que les
générations à venir ne vont pas nous
juger à l'aune de nom de notre force
militaire aujourd'hui mais me jugeront à
l'aune de notre capacité à résoudre les
problèmes à régler les conflits la force
militaire sans volonté de
construire
sans courage de dialoguer
de manière diplomatique ne va pas rendre
le monde ne va pas ça du monde un monde
plus pacifique nous avons besoin de
force à la table des négociations comme
nous avons besoin de force lorsque nous
défendons c'est la raison pour laquelle
l'allemagne a assumé ses responsabilités
au cours des deux dernières années au
niveau du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies et nous espérons pouvoir à
nouveau le fer en 2027 et 2028
mesdames et messieurs les ambassadeurs
mesdames et messieurs
oui nous avons échoué en afghanistan et
ceux de multiples à de multiples niveaux
cependant notre échec ne doit pas être
une ne doit pas être une raison ou une
cause ou une raison de sombrer dans là
pour nous pour les autres donc de le
faire preuve de schadenfreude et
j'utilise a et c
j'utilise donc
adc ans ce mot allemand qui est entré
dans passé dans beaucoup d'autres
langues schadenfreude
un état d'esprit par lequel si on
voulait expliquer
une perte pour quelqu'un est un gain
pour une autre mais ceci ce mot ne fait
pas véritablement justice à la réalité
du monde interconnecté dans lequel nous
vivons la stabilité régionale la
faiblesse des structures étatiques et
les réfugiés les flux de migrants
l'extrémisme religieux le terrorisme et
de nouvelles formes de conflits hybride
numérique environnementale sur l'épaule
et sur les ressources autant
d'évolutions qui nous menace tous et
auquel nous devons faire face l'aigle
petits comme les grands pays les grandes
puissances les etats-unis la chine et la
russie ont une responsabilité toute
particulière une responsabilité
particulière vis-à-vis des pays des plus
petits pays les privilèges des grandes
puissances et les privilèges dont
jouissent part dans les grandes
puissances un niveau du système des
nations unies ne se ne se justifie à
condition que celle ci assure la
promotion et défendre de l'ordre et
internationale basée sur la paix qui va
dans l'intérêt de tous et n'ignore pas
ou ne s'efforce pas de dominer dans là
pour atteindre leur leurs propres
intérêts les nations unies n'est pas un
ré les nations unies ne sont pas
vraiment un ring exemple de valeur à la
disposition des puissances mondiales
cependant
je je sais que là lorsque l'on pointe du
doigt les autres et bien cette main qui
pointe du doigt également des doigts qui
pointe vers nous
ce qui nous met en garde par exemple
d'un éventuel retrait américain ne doit
pas ne doivent pas succomber à des
réflexes similaire chez eux nous les
européens mais nous aussi les allemands
devons en faire davantage pour garantir
notre sécurité en faire davantage pour
la paix et la stabilité dans notre pays
et de par le monde nous devons
poursuivre nos efforts multilatéraux en
libye dans l'est de l'ukraine au
moyen-orient nous devons donc
relancer l'accord sur le nucléaire
et appelé l'iran à revenir à la table
des négociations le plus vite possible
mesdames et messieurs je pense je sais
que nous sommes d'accord
je sais que nous sommes d'accord avec
notre partenaire le plus proche la
france nous avons besoin effectivement
d'une politique sécuritaire et d'une
politique de défense commune plus forte
seule une europe plus forte pourra
attendre de ses partenaires de vous et
le rôle qui est le sien au niveau de
l'ordre international seule une europe
forte pourra
en même temps chercher la coopération
avec la chine lorsque la coopération va
dans notre dans le sens de nos intérêts
et donc nécessaire et en même temps
demandé à la chine de respecter les
droits de l'homme le droit international
ainsi que de respecter les intérêts tout
à fait légitime de ses voisins un ordre
international pacifique basé sur des
règles a également besoin d'un
partenariat transatlantique fort nous
savons que les etats unis se sont en
train de se fixer des prix aux jeunes
nouvelle priorité des priorités qui sont
quelque peu différentes et nous savons
que lorsque le monde de change ou si le
monde de changer bien nos alliances
doivent également s'adapter mais aucun
avantage à court terme
ne justifie de
ne justifie que des fissures
apparaissent dans notre unité
transatlantique il ne faut pas l'oublier
non plus la responsabilité des grandes
puissances y compris des puissances
européennes est d'autant plus importante
notamment lorsque nous appelons les
autres à relever les défis auxquels est
confrontée l'humanité en effet jamais
auparavant
avons-nous
fait l'expérience de notre
interdépendance du fait que nous
dépendions les uns des autres comme nous
l'avons fait au cours des presque deux
dernières années de la pandémie de
lakovic 19 et bien que nous sachions que
cette pandémie ne sera terminée que
lorsque elle sera terminée par tous eh
bien lorsque nous faisons le bilan de la
vaccination au niveau mondial et bien le
bilan est au mieux mitigé trop de
personnes attendent encore de recevoir
un vaccin qui sauvera leur vie c'est la
raison pour laquelle la distribution ne
doit pas être un instrument utilisé par
les pays
pour se faire mousser ou pour obtenir
des saveurs statique au contraire le
mécanisme kovacs lancé sous la houlette
des nations unies et je crois à la
meilleure manière de procéder
une d une dose de vaccin du mécanisme
kovacs sur trois est mise à disposition
par l'europe et en tant que deuxième
pays fournisseurs de doses de vaccins
mon pays contribuera à la fourniture
d'au moins 100 millions de doses
supplémentaires d'ici la fin de cette
année mesdames et messieurs
alors est ce qui est vrai pour la menace
existentielle que suppose cette pandémie
est tout aussi vrai lorsqu'il s'agit des
changements climatiques les feux de
forêt certains entrepôts l'apocalyptique
là
les tempêtes tropicales les ouragans la
perte de récoltes la canicule la
sécheresse la famine sont des réalités
sont des réalités ici elle suppose une
menace pour les peuples pour les
familles pour les moyens de subsistance
de ceci partout en particulier pour les
plus vulnérables également pour les pays
industrialisés est riche les
inondations dévastatrices dans l'est de
l'allemagne
cette année ont coûté la vie à près de 2
centres de mes compatriotes et nous vous
vous rappellerez des images plus
récentes ici à new york avec de l'eau
dans les rues dans les appartements dans
le métro alors étant donné cette toile
de fond
catastrophique que le retour à l'égoïsme
national
contre lequel je vous mets en garde
n'est pas qu'un simple pas en arrière et
vers le passé c'est quelque chose qui
peut nous priver de notre avenir de
notre avenir commun à tous ces quelques
quelque chose qui nuit aux institutions
et aux instruments dont nous avons
besoin et je pense que le moment est
venu de prendre des décisions
importantes ensemble à glasgow parce que
après tout lorsque l'on parle des
changements climatiques le fossé qui
s'exhibe entre nos ambitions nos
objectifs ambitieux et les politiques
très concrètes que nous mettons en
oeuvre est trop important et notre
mission à tous est justement de combler
ce fossé et nous devons le faire
maintenant parce qu'après tout nous
vivons nous vivons dans une époque où
l'humanité peut détruire de manière
irréversible les conditions de vie sur
notre planète et il incombe à nous à
notre génération de l'essai de
transmettre à nos enfants et à nos
petits-enfants un avenir ouvert nous
devons laisser
nous devons leur léguer un avenir qui
est ouverte dans lequel le changement
climatique ou la part dans la protection
du climat et de l'environnement la
prospérité économique un avenir dans
lequel une vie choisie vécu dans la
liberté et dans la cohésion sociale est
possible c est là je pèse mes mots
lorsque j'ai décidé d'utiliser cette une
c'est une
tâche une mission qui est historique
nous ne pouvons pas faire défaut à
l'humanité parce que c'est l'avenir de
l'humanité qui est en jeu mesdames et
messieurs j'ai commencé mon discours en
parlant de démocratie je vous ai parlé
de la transition démocrate démocratique
qui est en oeuvre dans mon paix dans mon
pays alors mes deux ans que je suis sur
le point de conclure ce de conclure mon
intervention je voudrait élargir un
petit peu mon angle des lectures et
revenir sur la situation de la
démocratie libérale dans son ensemble sa
crédibilité son incidence son avenir
alors que nous sommes un tournant
géopolitique difficile en afghanistan
un engagement de longue date qui a coûté
de nombreuses vies a échoué mais l'idée
qui se cache derrière cet engagement
elle n'a pas échoué mon pays il est
attaché à lille delà de la liberté de la
démocratie peut-être parce que nous
savons que le chemin pour y arriver a
été particulièrement long pour mon pays
pour mon pays
nous savons bien sûr que les systèmes
politiques ne sont jamais parfait dans
la réalité ni en europe et en amérique
nulle part par conséquent ils ne peuvent
ils ne peuvent être ni exporter
ni imposer
je pense que la miche thion accomplir
ici est différente il ne s'agit pas ici
de deux ce n'est pas le dirige par zèle
tel démissionnaire que nous devons faire
justice à cette formidable idée qu'est
la démocratie n'est en laissant tout
simplement la force de la démocratie
briller dans nos pays en
faisant sentir à nos citoyens la
démocratie tous les jours et en
résistant mais sur la tentation de
tomber dans l'autoritarisme
ici à l'assemblée générale le président
by day le président des états unis a
parlé du pouvoir de la démocratie et je
voudrais souligner ici que la démocratie
n'est pas quelque chose qui n'est pas
une force qui est utilisé contre qui que
ce soit il ne s'agit pas d'un instrument
de l'instrument occidentale de pouvoir
politique c'est un projet qui est en
cours quel que soit
le cap que l'on se fixe quel que soit
les frontières quelle que soit la
couleur de la peau des personnes c'est
un un projet un projet pour la liberté
un projet pour la dignité humaine que
les que les pays du monde us comme
maître de référence comme on de
référence dans la déclaration même dans
la déclaration même des droits de
l'homme et
parce que ceux ci continuent d'être
notre maître bien
se retirer du monde n'est pas non plus
une solution pour nous les allemands
même après l'échec en afghanistan alors
que des
peuples sont privés de leur dignité et
l'indifférence n'est pas une solution
c'est la raison pour laquelle davantage
de réalisme en politique étrangère ne
veut pas dire moins de responsabilités
et moins d'ambitions lorsqu'il s'agit
d'améliorer le monde dans lequel nous
vivons au contraire
l'être humain aspire à a toujours aspiré
à la dignité à la liberté et à
l'autodétermination faire justice à
cette aspiration humaine au lieu de la
réprimer c'est la véritable question qui
se pose et qui définira le 21e siècle et
cette question
ne sera pas tranchée sur un champ de
bataille parce qu'au final
la puissance de l'armée la plus
puissante arrive toujours donc les
munitions finissent toujours par
manquer le
lan le bras le plus longue de l'état le
plus fort
n'est jamais assez lent mais l'appel de
la démocratie et de liberté dans les
coeurs et les esprits du peuple lui
reste vivant j'en suis convaincu je vous
remercie
au nom de l'assemblée générale permettez
moi de remercier le président de
république fédérale allemande pour la
déflation qui vient de prononcer je prie
le protocole bien vouloir accompagner
son excellence